how are you doing today sir so good and
why do you choose the name collider
um
it's a long story it's from uh i'll make
it short because i think you want to
speak to me
uh sir there is nothing i want to say
yes then explain collider uh sure it's a
movie we cover movies and tv it's where
we call where cinephiles and fandom meet
uh i started the site in the summer of
2005. we have an awful lot of people
that read and watch the site so i was
wondering whether it had anything to do
with the
heightened collider uh where they beam
atoms and and knock adams out and look
after that so it is essentially the
collision uh yeah it's it's it's like a
melting place a melting pot and
the melting place is what to what
of where cinephiles and fandom meet
got it perfect
uh i've spoken to you in the past and i
will say it every single time it is
always a effing pleasure just to be able
to ask you questions i am a huge fan
thank you
um so i know this is for star trek one
through four on 4k but i have to ask you
um are you working at all on star trek 5
4k
at some point for the future
no they have not asked me
okay
maybe they forgot to ask me about 4k
i
uh well i hope they do ask you because i
would like to get all anyway that's a
whole separate thing so one of the
things about um filmmaking especially in
the last few years is that many films
get added vfx and sometimes they get
tweaked a little bit now that technology
has allowed us to you know make changes
and i'm just curious how do you feel
about say the star trek films having
newer added vfx added or slight changes
to fix maybe little bloopers that
happened do you feel that this is a good
thing or do you sort of feel like i i
understand what you're saying that in
its rawness it's part of its charm i
guess is what you're saying
and to fix it makes it slicker but that
wasn't the original you know that's an
interesting point do you make there
that in its mistakes it shows its
humanity and oh they didn't know that or
they made look at that i see a a coffee
cup there or something like that
in the haste
to make it
whereas they would jump in in a big
movie they would jump back and reshoot
it they couldn't afford it just leave it
there maybe they think it's an alien or
something
you know that's a really good point and
if i could argue
that it would be better to leave it
in all its
rawness and all its
energetic fumbling
uh as against slicking it up making it
look
pretty and nice whereas it wasn't so
pretty when it was made originally i
could argue that that's really good idea
to leave it alone
yeah i think that if they are going to
make tweaks to anything they always
should offer the original
on the same disk or you know what i mean
like always offer what was originally
that's expensive and then you know
printed twice they wouldn't want to do
that
um so robert jumping into the actual
star trek movies robert wise was a very
interesting choice as a director for the
first star trek film and i'm just
curious if you could sort of talk about
when you found out he would be helming
it what was your initial reaction and
what was it
robert wise had just come off uh
uh west side story i think it was uh he
was renowned he was like the popular
director so
as against his ability as a director
which i didn't know
he must have been he must have been
great because he had all these expensive
uh movies that to his credit and when
and i had seen west side story in the
camera work and thing was brilliant
although
he was shooting essentially
the the show that was uh
who directed west side story
oh robert why oh you're talking about
the play the musical yeah um who i don't
remember right i do vaguely uh a
renowned broadway director so he
essentially filmed the broadway show uh
and so
uh
the camera work was his i guess or the
camerawork was a brilliant cameraman and
robert said yes that looks good to me
um
so
he was he was a good director he was a
really good director
problem with that was
he was essentially an editor
he was editing the film in his mind uh
and
he never got to really edit it as his
primary talent was an editor uh i think
and uh
and he never got a chance to exercise it
because the movie had run into
delays on strikes
uh that happened during the filming so
we had to stop filming and then we'd
resume filming and and uh he ran out of
time to edit
and so the movie was shown without the
slickness of his editing
and it wasn't as polished as it could
have been and suffered as a result of
that
uh
yes
um i i spoke to you previously and you
said that you don't actually watch a lot
of the star trek stuff that you
haven't seen
exactly i am curious though if you were
sent the 4k
movies and if you happen to just turn
them on to see how good they look
i wouldn't
i don't need to look at them well no i
mean it's apologetics oh that's brighter
and the ship looks better that's cool
it's the story and what do i look like
and how are the performances and that's
that was the meaningful thing to me and
i i never i never liked what i looked
like and then i looked back and like oh
i didn't look that bad now i look bad
but i don't you know that was that's
just me
sir i i mean this really sincerely and
honestly you look fantastic
considering that you're only 50.
right
55
exactly um
so star trek 2 if i can jump into that
for a second
most people consider this the greatest
star trek movie your performance people
love
at what point making that film did you
realize this might be really good
the pro
i'll speak about me not with actors
if
if i go into something that i think is
terrible and and i have
i have to think it's really good
otherwise you know oh god
i don't know if that scene was any good
or not and the movie's not very good
this is a disaster i'm i'm why don't i
get out of here
i
i was uh
on a broadway-bound play opening here in
los angeles uh so we'd rehearse with a
renowned director and a great playwright
it was
it was his second play but it was really
his first
and i'm standing on
the apron of uh of a theater big theater
here in los angeles with an actress a
renowned actress and we're in darkness
and the the lights are going to come up
the curtain's going to go up the play is
going to begin opening in on our way to
to broadway
and she looks look turns to me in the
darkness and says are we in a disaster
and the curtain comes up now we got to
perform
so that little thing has always tickled
my mind or everywhere i go are we am i
in a disaster and that's the worst thing
you can think of so i thrust that out of
my mind and everything i do is the best
thing i've ever done
got it okay so you so when you were
making the film you didn't realize this
this is really turning out like no but i
felt good about playing the scenes
otherwise i wouldn't have you know i'd
have to feel good i'd have to feel
genuine
earnest honest
uh truthful uh
it sounds good to me in my
theater-trained mine i thought
i i think the audience will laugh or cry
or whatever it was i was trying to do
uh i have to i would have to feel good
about what i was doing otherwise i i
think every actor must have to feel that
otherwise my god it's like it's like
performing in front of people or a bull
get off the stage which has happened by
the way
uh before i run out of time i'm almost
out of time um i just want to touch on
star trek four real fast it is this
great fun movie that is this great
adventure and this amazing environmental
message back in the 80s when this was
not at the forefront of a lot of
different things i'm just curious if you
could talk about what you remember with
the making that film and how important
it was that it had this environmental
message
i had been into wales
long before that i had done a
performance of
of a great writer's poem whale's
weepknot and i done it to whale sounds
in front of 18 000 people i had been
into whales and i talked about whales so
i'm not sure where the whale thing came
from but i'm wondering i've always
wondered that was a coincidence
that this whale thing that i was into at
that time didn't
evoke
the whale concept i'm not sure
but
having been into wales and the story of
the whales the sounds of whales and the
and the demise of whales i was
i was so enthusiastic about the concept
of the whale thing and leonard did a
wonderful job directing it and
uh
the screenplay by um
oh i know the name um
oh my god uh that's the way it was
oh my god um
oh my god
oh my god i know the name but i can't
remember it right now um same here for
bennett maybe who uh i thought the
screenwriter
bennett
no he mean he was the producer
okay well let's say i can't remember
right me neither
i'll fix it in post please right
one one last thing though um is there
anything that you remember though about
specifically making that film or just
working with the cast
i guess if you could just reminisce a
little bit i would really appreciate it
well i remember
how at the end of the series the end of
the third year
how
devastated
we all were that the show was over we
all really loved the show
many of the scripts even people talk
about the third season nothing is good
you know it was great uh
uh we had um
something like 150 000 a show
i mean and that concluded our salaries
uh
so now they spend two three four five
million dollars on an hour uh so you can
see the handicap that would have been
there
but we all enjoy i enjoyed the show i
enjoyed doing the show right up to the
very end so i was very sad
that
again like
every actor
the reason equity exists is because
shows would close
out in the boonies
and the producer wouldn't have trained
fare for the cast to get back to new
york city so they started equity in
order just to get train fare to get back
that was the original reason for the
union uh
and and and so how to get back how to
and now it was council was all over and
then we wandered into the into the
bright lights of no work and
and uh you know
i had to do uh
uh in particular i was divorced and and
uh and broke because i got a divorce at
the same time
so it was a really turgid time for me
the cancellation and then when the
movies began and we got movies and my
life picked up and uh i was now working
a series in the movies and
it the continuity of life struck me the
the fact that if you can just exist for
a while longer
something good will and then keep trying
uh uh something good will will come
about
uh that was the the message as life
continued with star trek and otherwise
that life continues
uh sort of like now with uh conventions
and everything coming back right i got
to stop i could ask you a million other
things sir it is always a pleasure to be
able to talk with you i wish you nothing
but the best me too or for you